[موسيقى]
منعها من مواعده حبيبها فاستاجرت قتله
لانهاء حياه والديها ثم ظهرت كضحيه امام
العالم لكن ذلك القناع اخفى قاتله لم
تتردد في سفك دماء اقرب الناس اليها
الاسم جنيفر بان التهمه القتل العمد
المكان كندا الحكم السجن مدى الحياه
في بدايه فصل الشتاء بن نوفمبر عام 2010
كانت الفيتناميه جنيفر بان البالغه من
العمر 24 عاما انذاك في منزلها مع والديها
بمدينه ماركهام الكنديه عندما اقتحم ثلاثه
رجال منزلها واطلقوا النار على والديها ثم
قيدوا جنيفر واستدرجوها الى قبول المنزل
دون قتلها الشرطه الكنديه وصلت مكان
الجريمه وتمكنت من انقاذ حياه الوالد
الذين اعجوبه
وعلى الفور بدات التحقيقات في تلك القضيه
المشاهده الاوليه اشارت الى ان اطلاق
النار كان ضمن عمليه سطو خاطئه لكن الصدمه
جاءت بعد التحقيق مع جنيفرد فبعد يوم على
الحادثه اقتادت الشرطه جنيفر كشاهده
الشابه اعترفت لكنها ادلت باعترافات مضلله
فقالت انها اتفقت مع قتلت ماجورين لكن ليس
لقتل والديها وانما لقتلها هي لكن وبعد
ضغط من الشرطه خلال التحقيق افصحت الشابه
عن كافه تفاصيل الجريمه والشركاء الذين
استاجرتهم وتم لاحقا القبض على ثلاثه شبان
شاركوا في تنفيذ العمليه
بعض استيقاذه من غيبوبته اخبر والد جينيفر
الشرطه بانه راى ابنته تهمس لاحد المسلحين
وكانه صديقها
جنيفر قالت ان دافعها لقتل والديها كان
معاملتهم القاسيه معها والضغط عليها في
الدراسه وعدم السماح لها باستخدام هاتفها
ومنعها من مواعده صديقها مجددا بسبب
رسوبها في الثانويه العامه
محاكمه جينيفر بدات في التاسع عشر من مارس
عام 2014 واستمرت لعشره اشهر وبعد عده
مرافعات اذينت وشركائها في جريمه القتل
وحكم عليها بالسجن المؤبد مع عدم وجود
فرصه للافراج المشروط لمده 25 عاما
في النهايه انها جريمه مروعه لكن نظرا لان
الكثير من الاشخاص قد مروا خلال نشاتهم
بتجربه مثل جنيفر فمن المتوقع ان ينفجر
احدهم في النهايه قضيه جنيفر اثارت صدمه
في كندا والوسط الاسيوي ولخصتها صحف على
انها مثال حي للاباء النمور وهو مصطلح
يطلق على الاباء في اسيا الذين يهددون
اطفالهم ويعاملونهم بقسوه في حال فشلوا في
تلبيه توقعاتهم بالنجاح ما يؤدي في
النهايه الى بعض ردود الفعل الماساوي من
الابناء تماما كما حدث مع جينيفر